The past year has been
and continues to be
an incredibly stressful time
for just about everybody.
But for a lot
of white Americans like me,
it's also been a year of
recognizing just how much harder
that stress is hitting
black and brown Americans.
The COVID-19 pandemic
put a spotlight on the racial
disparities in health.
In the U.S., the death rate
among black people
is twice as high
compared to white people.
Black Americans in particular
are dying at double the rate
of their population.
Most of the bus drivers
in the city of Chicago
are black.
Most of the food service
workers are Latino.
Those populations are struggling
hard in all of this.
But the disproportionate effect
of this virus
is just one part of a long list
of racial gaps in health.
Would I be able to get
a subway map?
African Americans
are at greater risk
for developing
chronic diseases.
Reporter: More than
75% of black Americans
have hypertension,
compared with less than
50% of whites.
And when we talk about
why those gaps exist,
we often talk about
neighborhood,
socioeconomics,
and medical treatments.
But I'm wondering about
the experience of racism itself.
How does the stress
of living with discrimination
impact people's bodies?
Your age captures
how long you have lived.
But if you're living
in a bad environment,
your age is also capturing
how long you have been exposed
to bad environmental
conditions
and how physiologically
deteriorated
you have become as a result
of that exposure.
These microaggressions,
they accumulate over time.
It's like a death by
a thousand tiny little cuts.
( theme music playing )
So, I have this map.
What I would love to do
is map out
what life expectancy
looks like in New York,
depending on your neighborhood.
Okay.
- That kind of works.
- Okay.
So, we're gonna use green
for anything that is above
the New York City
average of 81.2,
and pink for anything
that is below.
Okay, so what is
Washington Heights?
84.4.
East Harlem is 77.9.
77.9
So, Upper East Side,
that's where we are right now.
- 86.4.
- Okay.
And this already is, like,
almost a ten-year difference.
Yeah,
it's a stark difference.
- Thank you.
- 86.3, Murray Hill.
One thing I think is really
interesting with these numbers
is, like,
if the Upper East Side
were its own country,
it would be like
the second best place to live,
for longevity in the world.
But then look at this.
As you're clustered here
- in East Harlem
and Central Harlem...
- Yeah.
...is not a good place
in terms of life expectancy.
Right, and people
in a majority white area
are living almost
a decade longer
than people in
a majority non-white area.
Huge difference.
Can you explain why that is?
Think about
the socio-economic
differences
between these
two communities.
- Yeah.
- That difference in income
would affect access
to quality healthcare,
food, transportation.
All of those
factors play a role
in life expectancy.
Yeah.
So, does socio-economic status
explain the whole picture?
No. I may be stressed
for other reasons.
You know,
I'm African-American,
maybe I'm having stressors
in my workplace,
or maybe I'm having stressors
finding a quality
health provider,
or maybe I feel like
I'm being discriminated against.
Whereas, you know,
someone that is not a minority
in the same socio-economic
status may not have
those same stressors.
So, in the U.S.,
your race plays a huge part
in how long
you can expect to live.
If you were Hispanic,
you can expect to live
to almost 82.
Almost 79, if you are white.
About 75, if you're black.
That is a three-year
age difference
between Hispanic people
and white people,
and a four-year gap
between black people
and white people.
So, even when you control
for education and income,
even the health behaviors,
there's still a gap.
I feel like
this all makes sense,
it's just never something
easy for me to accept.
So, those longevity counts
don't really
explain the full story.
So, if you look
at the percentage of people
who report being in very good
or excellent health,
among people who
self-identify as white
and are also socially
assigned white,
that number is 58%.
What does it mean to be
socially assigned white?
So, that just means people
perceive you as white.
And for people who
self-identify and socially
categorized as Hispanic,
the number is 47%.
So, despite longer
life expectancy,
fewer Hispanics report
being in good health.
That difference right there
is the health gap.
But if we look at people
who self-identify as Hispanic
who pass as white,
their health outcomes
are almost on par
with white people.
And we see that same effect
for Native Americans.
Those who pass as white
have health outcomes
that are almost on par
with white people.
And that difference
is even more drastic
for people
who are mixed race.
So, if you are mixed race
but you are perceived as black,
your health outcomes
wind up being much worse.
My biggest takeaway
from this is just how
proximity to whiteness
means that you're
gonna be better off.
So that means that
if they go to the hospital
or they're consulting
with some kind of
health professional,
they will probably
get better treatment.
It's fascinating,
the way whiteness works
when it comes
to health outcomes.
It's like regardless
of your background,
the way that you're seen
when you walk into a hospital
or you're walking
down the street,
that's what makes
the biggest difference.
Right. This plays out
for me personally.
I generally try
to avoid having to go
to the emergency room
because I'm just
always afraid about, again,
how I'm gonna be perceived.
Yeah, I never really
thought about how my race
personally affected me
as I, you know,
walk into a hospital room,
for example.
My absence of understanding,
my absence of knowledge
is the point.
That shows something about,
um, the privilege of ignorance
and of unawareness
of these things that
I've been able to have.
But discrimination varies
from place to place,
and that led me to this.
In 2015, a team of researchers
led by this professor
named David Chae
looked at the proportion
of Google searches
across America
- that used the "N" word.
- What? Okay.
Specifically the "N" word
ending in "E-R" or "E-R-S."
So that it gets rid
of any music lyrics,
things like that.
- Absolutely.
- It's not a perfect
measure of racism,
but it kind of provides,
like, a good proxy measure
of, like, the people
who are more likely to do that
are more likely to have
a negative racial sentiment.
So what they found is
for every one unit increase
of area racism
in each media market,
that corresponded
with a 5.7% increase
in black mortality.
- Racism kills.
- Right.
This is the first time
I'm hearing
of racism being
quantified in this way.
This is, like,
really interesting.
These three different studies
seem to show
that interpersonal racism
might be this overlooked factor
in negative health outcomes
in this country.
When someone says something
racist to you,
it's a comment that goes
to the core of your being.
Like, I cannot change
the pigment of my skin,
and it makes sense
that with every single incident
that you have to deal with,
with every racist encounter,
like, it's taking years
off your life.
That's crazy.
Not to mention that
the perpetrators
of those treatments
get to forget about it.
Truly forget! Yes.
And, you know, the people
on the receiving end
of that treatment
don't get that privilege.
Yeah.
All right.
We're about to call
David Williams.
He's a professor at Harvard
who studies the relationship
between race, racism,
and our health.
- Let's give him a call.
- ( Skype chiming )
Hi, Dr. Williams.
How's it going?
I am doing well.
How are you?
Pretty good.
How does discrimination
influence people's health?
So, we have known
for a long time
that stressful life experiences
adversely affect health.
And over the last
25 years or so,
we have expanded
the types of stressful
life experiences
that we study
to include experiences
of discrimination,
little indignities
that seem to chip away
at the well-being of individuals
on a day to day basis.
What we've found
is persons who score high
on experiences
of discrimination,
they're more likely
to get diabetes,
breast cancer, heart disease.
And the cumulative impact
of the psycho-social stress
and the economic stress
and the discrimination
leads to physiological
deterioration, to weathering.
They are literally
aging more rapidly
than the rest of the population
in the United States.
And how specifically
does the anticipation
of a racist encounter impact
the health of people of color?
Often, people are taking steps
before they even leave home
to minimize the occurrence
of these experiences.
And I'll be honest with you,
I feel physiologically
my blood pressure goes up
any time I see a police car
driving behind me.
And I've had good experiences
with the police,
but I've had bad experiences
with the police.
And it's that reality,
that threat,
um, has a physiological
cost for me.
And how does discrimination
affect people from one
generation to the next?
There are studies of survivors
of the Holocaust
that document changes
in gene expression
that puts those persons
who had the experience
at higher risk
of mental health problems,
such as PTSD.
And that epigenetic change
is evident also
in their offspring.
We haven't done that work yet
in studies of discrimination,
but women who report
everyday discrimination
while they are pregnant
are more likely to give birth
to lower birth weight infants.
But after the child is born,
there are a number of studies
that find experiences
of discrimination by the father
or by the mother
has negative effects
on the development of the child.
And if we wanted to measure
the weathering effect
over a lifetime,
how do we do that?
Looking at allostatic load
is one way
you can get a handle on that.
What exactly
is the allostatic load?
Christophe: You can think
of allostatic load
like a measure
of all of the wear and tear
on the body accumulated
over a lifetime.
So, in a way,
allostatic load gives us
a proxy measure of aging.
Now, to be clear,
some degree of stress is good,
but it's when
stress becomes chronic
that we start to see
really serious impacts
on our health.
Lee: And that's
what we've got here.
Christophe:
That's what we got here.
So we've built out this chart
with some of the best data
that we can find out there
about the racial stress gap.
- Should we get started?
- Let's do it.
- Okay.
- Show me how it's done.
So, on this chart,
red lines are gonna
be white respondents,
blue is black respondents
in this study.
- You want me to hold this?
- You slap the magnet down.
- Okay. Okay.
- And I'm gonna pull this.
- So, what's five mean?
- Five is a very high
allostatic load.
After four, that's
when we really start to see
- differences in
mortality rates.
- Wow. Okay.
So, it's 1.1
for white respondents
versus 1.6
for black respondents.
- This is the group
that we're in.
- Yeah.
( groans )
Wow, that one's
really stretched.
So now, the average
white respondent has 1.8,
compared to the average
black respondent at 2.2.
Just exposed to more stressors
as a black person.
I mean, that's just what
the numbers are pointing to.
The most anxious I feel
is walking home at night
walking into my building.
Not to be that guy,
but as far as I know,
I'm the only black person
that lives in my building.
I've had people ask me
when I come home with groceries
if I'm making a delivery
on one of these floors.
- I hate that part of the day.
- That's stress.
For what it's worth,
these numbers have been
adjusted for
socio-economic status,
so the difference
that we're seeing here
is more or less
a racial difference.
So, what happens
around 35 to 44?
- 35 to 44?
- The age my siblings are.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Now we're at the end here.
- Now we're at the end.
These are my folks.
White respondents had
an allostatic load of 4,
black respondents had
an allostatic load of 4.8.
- Jeez.
- I mean, this to me
is the most striking
part of this data,
is the fact that
black respondents were aging
a full decade faster
than the white respondents.
Yeah, this is crazy.
It also makes me
want to call my parents
and apologize for being such
an asshole when I was a kid.
- For causing them stress?
- Yeah, exactly.
Like, they had enough
to deal with.
I feel like I could've been
a slightly better son to them.
Yeah? Throughout
this entire series,
we've looked at
implicit biases and AI,
and disparities in
education and housing.
To me, the end result
of all of those things
is this chart.
It's the fact that the stress
of living in America
is so, so different
depending on your race.
Outside of getting this
very cryptic look at my future,
is there something I can do
to not end up here when I'm 60?
I think that's the tough part
about this whole episode, right?
Like, how do we even start
to talk about solutions
to health disparities
that come from such
structural inequalities?
I feel like the first step
is talking about it.
I have been in touch with
this group in Philadelphia
called Black Men Heal
that pairs black men
with free therapy.
So we could
go talk to them.
We should definitely
- Hello?
- Hey.
- How's it going?
- Hey, Christophe.
It's nice to meet you guys.
- Nice to meet you.
- Christophe.
- I'm Lee.
- Hey, Lee.
- Nice to see you.
- Not too much.
- Thank you for coming.
- Thanks for having us.
I'm Tasnim Sulaiman.
I'm the founder
of Black Men Heal,
a non-profit for men of color
to be able to receive
quality mental health care.
I found in the research
that black men are more likely
to listen
and be impacted by
men within the same
age category as them
and who look like them.
What feel like some of
the biggest reasons right now
that people are coming in
and seeking help?
Because of COVID, people
are quarantined by themselves.
It's a lot of job loss.
It's a lot of grief for people
that have died from COVID,
along with the racial uprisings
around George Floyd's death.
So, those issues
have increased a lot more.
Our young men of color
are at war every day.
With this year, that war
has been put on the front page
over and over again,
so they're experiencing
heightened anxiety.
So many guys were applying,
so we had to think
of something virtually to do.
So we started hosting
a segment based on
the different things
that were going on
in our country.
You know,
police brutality, grief.
Even for me, I--
Taj:
It's good, bro.
Like, I lost
a dear friend on Friday.
And that Sunday,
we talked about the pain
of losing somebody
and what it means,
and the fulfillment
and the value and the respect
that I got was other people
in the room was having
the same thoughts
or the same pain,
and they found out
they weren't alone.
You know, and I was talking
to Taj before this,
like, do men really know
how to cry?
- Mm-hmm.
- Because we've been told
so many different times
that, "Yo, just suck it up.
Don't show no tears."
For me, there's a sense
of a release.
How are you all going
about arming these men
with the language to articulate
what they're going through
in a world
that takes advantage of you,
especially when
you're a black male and you
present that vulnerability?
One man being willing
to step into a space
of vulnerability,
it's like putting
your hand out and inviting
another man to come in.
I think vulnerability
is like the new sexy.
Like, I think that's
a very powerful bond.
Thank you, Taz, for saying
vulnerability is sexy.
- Yes. It's the new sexy.
- I feel good about it.
- ( laughter )
- I'm bringing sexy back.
But, um, that transparency,
it is such a tough thing,
you know, growing up
having to put on a certain
facade, a certain image.
And I think about
Black Men Heal,
even the pairing up
with a therapist of color,
somebody that you can
actually identify with--
'cause if you go see somebody,
let's say, that's not black,
I know for me,
I'm already stereotyping
what you think of me,
so there is a fear right there.
And to be able to see
a therapist of color
gives you the freedom
to open up.
I actually have
a question for you.
- Oh, yeah?
- Have you ever taken
into consideration
race of the therapist
and been like,
"I don't feel
comfortable talking to you
because you're not--"
No, I mean, I think
that's something
that I have the privilege
of not thinking about
a lot of the time.
When I do go to the doctor
or other health services,
those are not crossing my mind.
I know a lot of times
we talk about the systematic
racism and, you know,
the black community is like,
"Why don't you understand?"
What we have to realize,
there's a reason why somebody
might not understand,
'cause they don't see
through that same lens.
You mentioned that there
are people as young as 18
and as old as 85
coming to Black Men Heal.
When you compare people
from generations so far apart,
what similarities
and differences do you see
in the things that
they're struggling with?
- Tons of similarities.
- More similarities than--
Taj: Yeah, and that's the hope
and the inspiration right there,
because you may hear
an older gentleman talk about
a scenario or a situation
that he's gone through,
but you're in it right now.
And so that lets you know,
"Hey, if he got through it,
I'ma get through it as well."
Black Men Heal saved my life,
and it saved me
from my own self.
It's the tools that I've learned
through Black Men Heal
that kept me stable,
that kept me grounded.
When I first started
reporting this story,
I felt shocked to see
that interpersonal racism
and the consequences of being
on the receiving end of it
could be measured
in this way,
and I felt curious
to understand it better.
But there's one thing
that Dr. Williams told me
that I can't stop
thinking about.
Williams: I think
for many white persons
in the United States,
it is a surprise.
But for many persons of color,
it's not a surprise.
But for some,
it is a powerful affirmation
that the experiences
we have had, um, are real,
and they actually
can be studied.
Whether you feel surprised
or validated by this research
is going to depend
on what you've experienced
in your own lifetime.
I can quote, like, verbatim
racist incidents
that took place about,
like, 10 years ago.
And so hearing that there's
research around this
just makes me feel--
I feel relieved.
Because it's like, great,
we're talking about this.
These numbers are out there.
Christophe:
Racism created
the racial health gap,
but anti-racism
can help close it.
That work, the work that falls
on each one of us every day,
is a matter
of public health.
We tend to put ourselves
in the shoes of someone
who belongs to the same
racial group that we're in.
One of the challenges we face
is how do we tell the stories
of disadvantaged populations--
the discrimination,
the stress,
the lower income,
and poverty.
They're living
in poor neighborhoods.
How can we tell those stories
in ways that connect
with the average American
so that they feel empathy
and then motivated
to support policy interventions
to address it?
Oh, no, we messed it up.
Oh, no!
- ( laughs )
- Carrie, did that hit you?
- Carrie: No.
- Thank God.
So, if you're Hispanic,
you can--
Why is that one smoking?
Oh! Where am I?
Okay, well,
this is embarrassing.